Kamala Harris does her big townhall
Howard Schultz preps his presidential
run and Democrats talk about Marxism I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
oh man a lot of news coming your way and
also a lot of me blowing my nose because
this cold just will not leave we'll get
to all the news in just a second but
first let's talk about the fact that in
2008 the US national debt was 10
trillion dollars and by the end of 2018
that that was over 21 trillion dollars
it is rising now like a hockey stick if
you don't think that we are sitting on a
house of cards you're living with your
head in the sand but since you're
listening to my podcast that probably
means that you are smarter than the
average American so what exactly is your
plan can you afford another hit to your
retirement like the last downturn when
the S&P dropped 50% he probably should
be diversified hedge against inflation
hedge against uncertainty and
instability with precious metals gold is
a safe haven against uncertainty my
savings plan is diversified and yours
should be as well the company I trust
with precious metal purchases Birch gold
group and thanks and right now thanks
for a little-known IRS tax law you can
even move that IRA or eligible 401k into
an IRA backed by physical gold and
silver if that's something that you are
interested in doing look back
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything else gold does tend to
safeguard savings
there's a reason Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews and a plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
contact Birch gold group right now get a
free information kit on physical
precious metals comprehensive 16-page
kit showing how gold and silver can
protect your savings and again how you
could legally move that IRA or 401k out
of stocks and bonds and into a precious
metals IRA if that's something you're
looking for to get that no cost no
obligation can't just go to
birchgold.com slash been again then it's
birchgold.com slash pin alright so it is
obvious that the radical Democratic base
has now taken over the entire party
because there are no centrist left who
are running for president in 2020 in the
Democratic Party it's amazing to watch
as members of the media label random
members of the Democratic coalition
centrist so they've been making the
claim that Kamala Harris the senator
from California is the new centrist
she's a centrist voice as opposed to
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders now
the reason that they are saying that is
because she had a history as a
prosecutor so that means that naturally
she is more centrist than a lot of the
other Democratic members of the
coalition the only problem is she isn't
and she served as a prosecutor because
she fell
that would be a gateway to higher office
but the reality is that Kamala Harris is
every bit the radical of Elizabeth
Warren or Bernie Sanders or Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez or anybody else who you
think is the face of the radical
Democratic Party now she's getting hit
from the West today and the reason she's
being hit from the left is again because
of that prosecutorial career there's a
clip going around of her speaking at the
Commonwealth Club in San Francisco
really nice group of folks and it's it's
a clip of her back when she was Attorney
General of the state of California
talking about how she used to prosecute
the parents of kids who were truant
here's what she said she said I believe
a child going without it without an
education is tantamount to a crime so I
decided I was going to start prosecuting
parents for truancy well that was a
little controversial in San Francisco
and you can actually see her laughing in
the tape
she was frankly my staff went bananas
they were very concerned at the time we
didn't know at the time whether I was
gonna have an opponent to my re-election
race I said look I'm done this is a
serious issue I've got a little capital
I'm gonna spend some of it and this is
what we did we recognized as a
prosecutor in law enforcement I have a
huge stick the school system has a
carrot let's work in tandem around our
collective objective and goal which is
to get those kids in school well the
internet was going nuts over this last
night because the suggestion is that
Kamala Harris was going after parents of
kids who were truant and really what you
require is a social worker in these
cases you don't require a police officer
now it's kind of fascinating to watch as
the left resonates to Kamala Harris
despite her record in this particular
area it is also important to note that
when she says something should be
tantamount to to a crime you as Attorney
General do not get to decide what is and
is not a crime you do not get to decide
that everything you don't like is now
enforceable by the police if you do that
makes you a centralized government
control tyrant and and Kamala Harris
does have those tendencies but all of
that is being pushed to the side by the
fact that Kamala Harris is an
intersectional candidate she's female
and she's black and that means that she
must be a great great candidate even if
she's spouting the same nonsense that
all the other Democratic candidates are
spouting ad nauseam so last night rain
in a town hall on CNN and it was just a
wonderful example of CNN again playing
host to a propaganda piece on behalf of
a Democrat so she's in front of a group
of people probably you know 400
five hundred people maybe and I love
that CNN was like well she did this in
Des Moines Iowa and CNN was touting this
online wow look at the crowd common low
Harris can draw not to be not to be
self-centered here for a second I have
not spoken to a crowd smaller than 500
people in probably three years and I'm
not a senator from California so it's
pretty amazing that people are now
touting this as an example of her
ability to get people out there
I mean CNN's broadcasting this thing
live you think CNN is gonna be
interested in hosting an event that has
a bunch of empty seats in the background
in any case she's asked a bunch of
questions about policy and she proved
just how radical she is so she was
specifically asked about private health
care insurance so she is a proponent
proponent of Medicare for all the Bernie
Sanders plan that would cost 32 trillion
dollars over ten years it would double
the size of the federal government
it would also destroy the private sector
now there are a lot of folks who say
well you know Medicare for all wouldn't
destroy the private sector because
health insurance would still continue to
exist in the private sector but
according to Camilla Harris she actually
wants it to destroy private sector
medical insurance
she believes that everybody should be
thrown onto government care that you
shouldn't be able to by private sector
health insurance because once the
taxpayer is footing the bill for
Medicare number one there's not gonna be
a ton of money left over to pay for
private health care insurance to most
people are going to be getting their
health care insurance through the
government of the United States and
three if you have private health
insurers competing with the federal
government that's not good for the
federal government because the federal
government is then going to have its
care rejected this is the great hole in
a lot of these systems you can have
supplemental health insurance in a lot
of in a lot of nationalized health care
countries for example in Canada you can
get supplemental health insurance
although it took a while for them to
allow even that in Israel now you can
finally get supplemental health
insurance in Australia most people have
private supplemental health care
insurance Medicare for all in Australia
is really just for basic care but for
full proponents of Medicare for all
people who believe that the government
should cover all cost it's gonna come
down to rationing and it's gonna come
down to banning private health care
insurance because remember let's say
that there's a private health care
insurers are something and that private
health care in sure can offer doctors a
better reimbursement rate than Medicare
well who do you think the doctors are
going to look to in order to
patience are they gonna look to Medicare
or I think it'll look to the private
health care insurers that's why many
countries have outright ban private
health care insurance they don't want to
compete with the private sector they
want to crowd the private sector out so
carmella Harris was asked specifically
about this and she came down full-scale
on the side of nationalization of the
health care system and full-scale
destruction of private health insurance
here is Camilla Harris doing just that
I believe the solution and I'm and I'm
actually feel very strongly about this
is that we need to have Medicare for all
and you don't have to go through the
process of going through an insurance
company having them give you approval
going through the paperwork all of the
delay that may require who of us has not
had that situation where you got to wait
for approval and the doctor says well I
don't know if your insurance company is
gonna cover this let's eliminate all of
that let's move on so in other words 95
percent of people in the United States
have healthcare from their insurance
company via their employer you if you
like your doctor you will not be able to
keep your doctor if you like your plan
you will not be able to keep your plan
she wants to take all of those things
directly from you I mean this is a
massive segment of the United States
economy if you think that you're going
to remove legitimately like a trillion
dollars from American industry with no
questions asked and that people are
gonna be supremely happy when you take
away their health plan then think again
think about Obamacare the Obamacare is a
piece of crap legislation but the thing
about Obamacare is that Obamacare was
purportedly about trying to help people
in the individual market if you had your
health insurance program through your
employer Obamacare theoretically did not
touch it no that's not true Obamacare
didn't regulate the insurance companies
and make it nearly impossible for you to
get the same level of care at the same
cost as you did before
raised health care cost across the board
but it was specifically driven by the
needs in the individual market people
who had lost their jobs and had a health
problem and now couldn't get health
insurance but it was not directed at
destroying the entire system Kamala
Harris Bernie Sanders now these are
folks who want to destroy the entire
system from the very center of the
system they want your plan to be gone
they want your doctor to be gone there's
an amazing statement by Kamala Harris to
just come out and say that part she said
the quiet power it out loud now
everybody knows that that is where this
is going but everybody is pretending
that that is not where this is going
right now
right here's what Kamala Harris actually
said
said she felt very strongly about
medicare-for-all and then when she was
pressed by Jake Tapper if that means
eliminating private insurance she said
yes she said yes she said the idea is
everyone gets access to medical care
okay and then she said let's just get
rid of it said there's no let's just be
done with it well I'm glad that she can
summarily dismiss 25% of the American
economy right off the top and by the way
the part of the economy that also
happens to generate all of the medical
innovation that also happens to generate
all of the all of the profit incentive
for doctors to go into the industry in
the first place Democrats are incredibly
extreme on this stuff all Trump should
do for the next two years of Kamala
Harris is indeed the Democratic nominee
has played the clip of her over and over
and over again saying she's gonna take
away our healthcare program she's gonna
take away our health insurance and let's
see how the elderly feel about that
let's see how you feel about that when
she says she's taking away health
insurance for your child so that you can
work with a government bureaucrat I also
love the suggestion by Kamala Harris
there that the solution to all of your
paperwork ills is the federal government
since when has that ever been true has
there been any area of American life in
which your life has been made simpler by
the federal government like less
paperwork I highly doubt it but that
wasn't her only extreme statements of
the night she was also asked
specifically about guns and she said
that we should basically ban all
semi-automatic weapons in the United
States there is no reason in a civil
society that we have assault weapons
around communities that can kill babies
and police officers there is no reason
why we cannot have reasonable gun safety
laws in this country and guess what guys
here's the reality of it all so we're
not waiting for a good idea we have the
good ideas an assault weapons ban
background checks okay so you know she
she then went on and she specifically
said you know what we should do we
should force legislators we should force
legislators to look at autopsy photos
because then this is the the ugliest
part of American politics right now the
idea that if you disagree with Kamala
Harris about her gun proposals it's
because you just don't care about the
children if only you cared about the
children then you would agree with her
that all semi-automatic weapons in the
United States when she says assault
rifles she means semi-automatic weapons
that all semi-automatic weapons in the
United States ought to be banned or
confiscated outright you were talking
about 100
of millions of weapons in the United
States and she suggests that if I
opposed her stupid policy then that's
because I don't care about dead kids
here she is doing this routine twenty
six and seven-year-old babies were
massacred in Connecticut they fail to
act here's what I think I think that
somebody should have required and this
is gonna sound very harsh I think
somebody should have required all those
members of Congress to go in a room in a
locker room no pres knowing nobody else
and look at the autopsy photographs of
those babies and then you vote your
conscience okay so we're gonna force
them to look at the pictures Kamala
Harris wants them to look at in order to
get them to change their mind okay fine
if she wants that to be the case then
how about this how about every Democrat
in the United States Congress has to
look at a picture of an aborted baby at
22 weeks and then they can vote their
conscience on free-choice then they can
vote their conscience on whether it's
okay to slaughter babies in the world
but people on the Left would say well
you know that's an emotional appeal it's
not a logical appeal well that's exactly
what Kamala Harris is doing there with
regard to slaughtered kids in classrooms
the suggestion that I'm supposed to give
up my rifle because something bad
happened to kids not perpetrated by me
and whom I somebody I would have
attempted to stop if I'd been there with
my gun yeah we'll get to more of the
extremism of Kamala Harris in just a
second first let's talk about life
insurance so I know it's uncomfortable
to talk about the fact that we're all
gonna plotz at some point but because we
know that we also know that we need a
life insurance it's just part of being
an adult but you know sometimes it's
complicated you do it by word of mouth
you don't know exactly had about how to
go about doing it this is why you need
policy genius polishing genius has
created a website that makes it easy for
you to compare quotes get advice and get
covered policy genius is indeed the easy
way to get life insurance in minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers and
find the coverage you need at a price
you can afford from there you just apply
online and the advisors of policy genius
handle all the red tape for you they
will even negotiate your rate with the
insurance company no extra fees no
Commission sales agents just helpful
advice and personalized service and
policy genius doesn't just do life
insurance whether you're shopping for
disability insurance to protect your
income or homeowners insurance or auto
insurance they can help you get covered
fast so no matter how much or how little
you know about life insurance you can
find the right
policy in minutes at policy genius.com
again that's policy genius calm
policy genius is the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance go check them out
right now policy genius.com though check
them out okay so Pamela Harris making
the case that we should ban all assault
rifles in the country so so far we have
we're gonna ban private health insurance
and we're going to ban all our
semi-automatic weapons in the United
States but that's not all from common
law Harris she also continues by saying
that we should basically ban all private
private vehicles in the United States
she said she backs the green New Deal
right this is this is the new fresh
thing among Democrats is the green at
New Deal
now as you'll recall the green new deal
is this purported piece of legislation
that would radically shift the nature of
the American economy the idea is that
within a decade we would be completely
carbon fuel free we would no longer be
using gas we would no longer be using
coal we would be carbon neutral and the
idea here is that we require a vast
shifting of how the American economy
works the cost on this green new deal by
the way would be 18 trillion dollars 18
a trillion dollars over the over the
course of the next decade or so sorry
I'm under estimating the green new deal
according to PJ Media analysis would
cost 49 trillion dollars in the first at
ten years right that's an amazing
amazing statement but it doesn't matter
the entire left has decided to resonate
around all of this the green new deal
would include a federal jobs program it
would include getting rid basically of
all private cars here is Kamala Harris
supporting it we've been hearing more
about a green new deal to fight climate
change you have yet to fully endorse or
reject it will you fully endorse the
green new deal tonight I support a green
new deal and I will tell you why climate
change is an existential threat to us
and we have got to deal with the reality
of it all children need to be able to
breathe clean air and drink clean water
and we've got to have a commitment to a
policy that will allow that to happen
for ourselves and our children and our
grandchildren and right now we don't
that green new deal that she is
endorsing right there requires cutting
the United States military in half
ending 87% of us energy and banning cars
so that is it that is the new program
that she is
supporting Kamala Harris very exciting
stuff if you think that this is
mainstream thought it is inside the
Democratic Party it's pretty astonishing
it's pretty astonishing so so far ban
guns ban private health care and banned
cars but but at least but at least we
know she's a moderate that's that's the
really important thing is at least we
know that Kamala Harris is a big
moderate according to members of the
Democratic Party
then finally Harris got to her
prosecutorial record so as you say she's
pandering to the left she's just as left
as Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren
and she was asked specifically about her
prosecutorial record and this is where
she's gonna have a little bit of trouble
with the radical left inside her own
party I compare my record to any
prosecutor any elected prosecutor in
this country in terms of the work that I
have done to reform the criminal justice
system I am a daughter of parents who
met when they were active in the civil
rights movement nobody had to teach me
about the disparities in the criminal
justice system I was born knowing what
they are I made a conscious decision to
become a prosecutor because I understood
if we're gonna reform systems yes there
is gonna be the power that we have on
the outside and also we need to have
people on the inside where the decisions
are being made by the way the question
she was asked was why she did not
support a bill requiring her office to
investigate fatal shootings involving
police officers and her answer was I'm
black and that's why I became a
prosecutor which is not a good answer
she's gonna get flack from the left and
from the right on her prosecutorial
record the good news is that the flag
from the left is only gonna last so long
as the media focus on the question which
is to say not long at all there instead
going to focus on the radical leftist
policy she takes on for example border
security
so she was asked last night about her
position on a border wall and she said
something so radical that most Democrats
I would think disagree with it which is
that she will not be in favor of a
border wall under any circumstances even
if it means guaranteeing the legal
status of so-called dreamers who are
already in the United States under any
circumstances and I do support border
security and if we want to talk about
that let's do that and let's talk about
what really accomplishes border security
which is let's upgrade the technology
let's look at the fact that the folks
who are working on border security on
the ground know that they need upgraded
infrastructure around things like drones
and they need
cameras so yes I'm all for increased
border security where we need it I am
NOT for a while okay so she still can't
explain what kind of border security she
wants just something that drones in
cameras but that really doesn't solve
any of the question and saying that she
would leave the dreamers hanging
specifically to avoid Trump's program is
pretty amazing stuff there's an article
in The New York Times today that does
point out a serious flaw for camel-hair
so I've pointed out her prosecutorial
record here a couple of times it is -
right wing for the left and - left wing
for the right well the New York Times
has an article today talking about how
that could really impact Kamala Harris's
race with regard to black voters so the
title of the piece is can Kamala Harris
repeat Obama's success with black voters
it's complicated
they say interviews with more than 30
black voters and political leaders in
early primary states like South Carolina
and her home state California show that
Miss Harris faces challenges she'll have
to persuade black activists skeptical of
her record as a prosecutor overcome
sexism and a bias on the part of some
voters that a female candidate cannot be
President Trump and worked to gain
broader support from black men who
generally expressed more wariness about
Miss Harris in interviews than black
women she would also need to win over
left-leaning young black voters some of
whom were ultimately disenchanted by mr.
Obama's presidency and may value
political ideology more than racial
solidarity so she does have some
problems in this race the good news is
she may be able to pan or her way out of
it so the way she's gonna pander her way
out of it is by invoking stupidities
like mansplaining
she's going to explain that everyone who
opposes her is just a sexist so she was
asked about mansplaining last night in a
typical left-wing question here is the
charisma free Kamala Harris given what
occurred in 2016 and the current
political climate that a male nominee
will have a better chance this time
around than a female nominee would you
please respond to this so that this man
has a response ready the next time a man
tries to mansplain why a man would make
a better nominee
people who vote the people who live in
this country are smarter than that
they're gonna make decisions based on
who they believe is the best leader
who they believe is speaking truth who
is doing it in a way that gives people
dignity doing it in a way that elevates
public discourse as opposed to bringing
us to the lowest common denominator and
base instincts that's how the voters are
gonna vote and that is gonna be the
basis upon who will win you know that
the question is really hard-hitting when
the candidate stands up and applauds the
question I love guys who ask women about
man's planning that guy that's a real
man's man right there that guy who her
about man slating solid solid stuff so
that that's really exciting Kamala
Harris was also asked about how she
would stay on message debating President
Trump once again her answer was less
than inspiring well first I it's very
important that anyone who who presents
themselves as leader and wants to be a
leader will speak like a leader and that
means speaking with integrity can mean
speaking truth
and speaking in a way that expresses and
and indicates some level of interest and
concern in people other than oneself
okay honestly I I think that if she ends
up being the Kansa de for the Democrats
I think Trump has a pretty good shot of
meeting her I'll explain why in just a
second like really the more I see her
the more comfortable I am with President
Trump running against her I'll explain
in just one second first let's talk
about frame bridge they make it super
easy and affordable to frame your
favorite things from art prints and
posters to the photos sitting on your
phone so you got a bunch of photos on
your phone on your computer you're not
sure what to do with them you don't want
to schlep on over to the local frame
store which is super expensive and they
make you pay a fortune for custom frames
instead you should be looking at frame
bridge with Valentine's Day approaching
you can create a unique and thoughtful
gift that will last for years to come so
here's how it works you just go to frame
bridge comm and you upload your photo or
they'll send you packaging to safely
mail in your physical pieces preview
your item online in any frame style
choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their design team
the experts at frame bridge then custom
frame your item and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door
ready to hang instead of the hundreds
you'd pay at a framing store their
prices start at just 39 bucks all
shipping is free plus my listeners get
15% off their first order at frame
bridge comm when they use promo code
Shapiro's so my wife and I we took our
two kids for vacation in Hawaii and we
did a photo shoot the photos are
beautiful but we're looking for frames
frame bridge is the place that we went
go check them out right now at frame
bridge calm and use promo code Shapiro
save an additional 15% off your first
order again frame bridge comm promo code
Shapiro frame bridge compliment code up
here to get 15% off your order it's a
great way to make sure that you are
preserving your memories okay so I'm
looking at this tape of Kamala Harris
last night on CNN and here's what I'm
seeing I'm seeing a person who is
radically pandering to the far-left I'm
seeing somebody who's struggling with
her own record as a prosecutor and I'm
seeing somebody who is giving
platitudinous answers to obvious
questions she's not really exciting is
the thing hey Barack Obama could do this
because he was the first Barack Obama
but you can't be the first Barack Obama
if you're the second páramo you just
happened to be female there's nothing
particularly exciting about common law
Harris and the media trying to
manufacture her excitement for her his
pretty ins pretty astonishing honestly
because she is not an exciting candidate
when you watch her if you're on the Left
you watch her and you go wow she is
she blows me away or does she feel a lot
more like sort of a typical politician
than something brand new and exciting
there's no sizzle there you know Donald
Trump if you got a stage with Donald
Trump and Kamala Harris it looks a lot
more like the stage of Donald Trump and
Hillary Clinton that it looks like
Donald Trump versus Barack Obama for
example she's just not nearly as
talented a politician as Barack Obama
was I mean few people are I mean I think
that's that's not a rip on her that's
just a reality Barack Obama was a very
talented politician she happens not to
be she ran in a very safe state in
California she was given her she was
given her first lift in politics by a
man a married man she was dating she's
had a pretty easy ride to the position
that she now occupies there is nothing
about her that makes people stands up
and Cheer really I mean they're totally
should cheer by the media they're told
that they should cheer because we need a
black female president as opposed just a
black male president we don't need a
black female president but if you are
progressive are you more excited by her
or are you more excited by the full on
Marxism of Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders if you are if you are a
millennial are you really excited by
Kamala Harris does she strike you as
somebody who is gonna make you get out
there and pound on doors I don't think
so and I think that she's also gonna get
Republicans out there to vote on mass I
mean she is she is saying openly that
she is going to destroy the entire
private health care system in the United
States now when Elizabeth Warren says it
I guess that lefties get excited but
when Kamala Harris says it it just feels
like she's a government bureaucrat who
spends her entire life being a
government bureaucrat and doesn't know
what she's talking about
so I don't know I've got more questions
about Kamala Harris his candidacy today
than I had yesterday and I'm shifting on
this based on new evidence yeah I was
suggesting that she's the front-runner
and I think that with all the media
attention she will leap to the front of
the pack for a time but I'm not sure
that lasts because I don't think that
she is particularly exciting maybe I've
got this totally wrong I just don't get
that feeling from her now the way that
you know the Democrats are a little bit
panicked is by the reaction to Howard
Schultz Oh Howard Schultz is the former
Starbucks CEO but he is now talking
about running for president of the
United States he's talking about running
basically as a middle-of-the-road
Democrat and Democrats are panicked
about this I mean freaking out so last
night he was doing a book event and it
was a town hall event
and some guy got up and started yelling
at Howard Schultz about not running for
president please don't run for president
you're going to keep Trump in the Oval
Office I am seriously considering
running for president as a centrist
independent and I wanted to clarify the
word independent which I view merely as
a designation on the ballot okay so I
love that people are really upset about
this it's not just that random guy in
the audience I mean frankly I don't
understand what cory booker is doing out
there in the audience shouting at him
and don't help elect Trump but Democrats
are so threatened by the possibility of
a centrist Democrat running that they're
getting up and shouting at Howard
Schultz now the way to stop people from
voting for Howard Schultz if you're a
Democrat is to nominate somebody who
isn't bat bleep crazy is to nominate
somebody who isn't pledging to destroy
1/4 of the American economy til you
nominate somebody who doesn't pledge to
remove guns from the hands of a hundred
million people well you start with that
have you nominated somebody who wasn't
quite as nutty then maybe you wouldn't
have to worry about Howard Schultz but
the fact is that Democrats in the base
want their cake and they want to eat it
too they want to be able to nominate
somebody radical without alienating
everybody in the middle this is why
Michelle Goldberg over at the New York
Times did a sheer panic today Michelle
Goldberg who's legitimately the the
stable over at the New York Times this
stable of just awful columnist it really
is amazing but Michelle Goldberg has a
piece today called Howard Schultz please
don't run for president a bid by an ex
chief of Starbucks would be reckless
idiocy why would it be any more idiotic
than Elizabeth Warren running for
president
well because Howard Schultz is moderate
so here's what Michelle Goldberg says
she's unlike Donald Trump
the former Starbucks chief executive
Howard Schultz is a genuinely successful
businessman who built a company that's
become part of the daily lives of people
across America for this those of us who
are horrified by Trump's relentless
grifting should be grateful it gives us
something concrete to boycott should
Schultz decide to launch a narcissistic
spoiler campaign for president so she's
happy that he is associated with
Starbucks because then they can boycott
Starbucks worth noting Michelle Goldberg
is so dumb that she doesn't even
recognize that he's the former Starbucks
CEO he is no longer associated
Starbucks so she's gonna boycott a
company he's no longer involved in
brilliant but here's what Michelle
Goldberg writes I mean it didn't even
have editors over at the New York Times
anymore
she says he could end up help him get
Donald Trump re-elected Schultz appears
to share the conviction endemic among
American elites that the country hungers
for a candidate who is socially liberal
but fiscally conservative after all if
you're rich you probably know a lot of
people like this I'm socially liberal
fiscally conservative centrist who would
love to vote for a rational Democrat and
get Trump out of the White House a chief
executive of a major bank who wanted to
remain anonymous recently told POLITICO
lamenting Michael Bloomberg's poor odds
in a Democratic primary but this
frustrated executives politics aren't
widely shared by people who haven't been
to Davos in a 2017 study the political
scientists lead Rutman plotted the 2016
electorate along two axes one dealing
with social issues and identity the
other with economics and trade only 3.8
percent of voters fell into the socially
liberal economically conservative
quadrants so then here's the question
what is Michelle Goldberg so scared of
why is she so scared well what what you
worry about if nobody in the Democratic
Party is gonna vote for this guy then
what is she worried about is she worried
about what's her face from marianne
williamson who announced she's gonna run
for president is she worried about
marianne williamson why isn't there a
column in The New York Times about the
kooky yoga instructors who are gonna
vote for Marianne Williamson the answer
is nobody knows who she is and she's not
gonna win any votes so if there's no
constituency for Howard Schultz why is
Michelle Goldberg all upset about his
possible candidacy so here's what she
says she says Bloomberg's researcher
underscores the folly of Schultz's trial
balloon on Monday Bloomberg was
contemplating a 20/20 run as a Democrat
put out a statement that seemed aimed at
Schultz though it didn't mention him by
name in 2020 the great likelihood is
that an independent would just split the
anti-trump vote and end up reelecting
the President Roh Bloomberg that's a
risk I refused to run in 2016 and we
can't afford to run it now by flirting
with such a risk Schultz is
demonstrating a level of megalomaniacal
recklessness
that is itself disqualifying so the fact
that Schultz thinks maybe I should run a
race because there's a bunch of people
who don't like either party that's a
megalomaniacal now so there's no so you
can't have it both ways either no one's
gonna vote for him so why are you
worried or everyone's gonna vote for him
so maybe he should run by Michelle
Goldberg and many in the Democratic
Party want it both ways
they know they're too radical for the
American people and it freaks them out
that somebody might be running a
third-party candidacy that could damage
a beloved candidate like Elizabeth
Warren or Kamala Harris or Bernie
Sanders okay in just a second I want to
get to more of Howard Schultz's program
and why Democrats should feel threatened
by it first let's talk about the coffee
you had this morning now was it that
good I guess mediocre you want better
coffee morning coffee is an American
institution which is why when it comes
to starting my day I reach for the most
American coffee on the market
black rifle coffee black rifle coffee
gives a portion of their sales to vets
and first responder causes black rifle
coffee is roast - guaranteeing you fresh
delicious coffee with every single order
black rifles coffee club makes things
easy you just pick your blend in the
amount you want and black rifle ships
your coffee direct to your door every
month hassle free wake up with America's
coffee black rifle coffee visit black
rifle coffee calm slash been received 15
a percent off your order at his black
rifle coffee calm / been for 15% off
again
black rifle coffee calm / man go check
them out right now I know the folks who
run it these are not the PC folks who
are gonna be ensuring that their their
coffee shops turned into bathrooms stop
fur and O's these are folks who actually
just want to make good coffee and bring
it to your door and then give some money
to vets and First Responder causes great
folks over there black rifle coffee calm
/ Ben and get their roasts to order
coffee club to make sure that everything
is arriving at your door in a regular
basis black rifle coffee calm / men okay
I wanna get to more of Howard Schultz
and Democratic radicalism in just a
second but first you're gonna have to go
subscribe over at daily wire comm $9.99
a month gets you a subscription to daily
wire when you do that rest of the show
live rest of claim in the show live
restive knows this show live most
importantly an extra two hours of yours
truly each and every day you can hear
that I'm sick you know why because I'm
slaving away for you people go check it
out right now $9.99 a month gets you
subscription you can ask questions in
the middle of the show we do that
sometimes it's a lot of fun and the only
way you can have that show on demand is
by going to daily wire comm for $99 a
year you can get all of those glories
plus this the very greatest in beverage
vessels the leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr feast your eyes upon it and
despair that you have it not go check
out the leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr right now and spend 99 bucks a
year get all of the great services we've
talked about also subscribe
YouTube and iTunes get our Sunday
specials you can get our daily wire
backstages all sorts of great stuff
happening over at daily wire comm we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so Democrats are in a full state full
scale state of panic over Howard Schultz
and he's actually building out a team he
has now hired X Obama aide Bill Burton
as a communications adviser as it's the
former CEO Starbucks Starbucks CEO moles
running for president in 2020 he's
adding people on both the right and the
left to his campaign Burton is looking
to bring on other public relations
representatives in order to promote
Schultz's story of being raised in
Brooklyn New York to becoming a
prominence executive in the business
industry the addition of Burton could
potentially boost Schultz his elite PR
team which already includes Steve
Schmidt who used to be a vice chairman
at Edelman and managed to John McCain's
presidential campaigns and this could be
a true quote/unquote centrist campaign
now what's fascinating is that the left
feels that they have not adequately
served their base you're not seeing a
lot of people who are who are Trump fans
who are deeply worried about Howard
Schultz's campaign about Schultz playing
spoiler why well because conservatives
are pretty conservative and Bloomberg
and and Schultz is not conservative
enough for them but folks on the Left
feel that they have sort of had to put
one leg on each stone they've got one
leg on the more moderate stilt and
they've got one leg on the radical stilt
and the radical stilt is moving away
from the other stone very quickly and
that means pretty soon they're gonna
lose their balance opening away for a
third party candidates win maybe 15-20
percent of the vote so Trump could then
win 43 44 percent of the vote Howard
Schultz picks up 15 percent of the vote
and the Democrat loses the race that is
what they are worried about right now
and they shouldn't worry about that
again the solution would be not to be
radical crazy people but they can't do
that because it turns out there are
radical crazy people's they're not going
to do that so Howard Schultz if you look
at what he's been saying a lot of it is
true and a lot of it I think appeals to
people in the center so for example he
was specifically asked about Democratic
health care plans now you already saw
earlier in the program senator Kamala
Harris talking about how she wants to do
away with all private health insurance
in the United States of America an
insane position it in same position that
will end with massive number of doctors
going into concierge cash for payment
don't end with hospitals going bankrupt
that will end with people getting poorer
care and rationed care
here's Howard Schultz talking about how
these health care plans they're just not
realistic
every American
deserves the right to have access to
quality health care but what the
Democrats are proposing is something
that is as false as the wall and that is
free health care for all in which the
country cannot afford okay and that of
course is exactly true the country
cannot afford a quote unquote free
health care for all
there is no system on planet earth that
makes that makes health care affordable
Universal and quality there's no way to
do it you know and when I say affordable
Universal and quality I mean that if you
want the best in choice you are going to
have to have a free-market system now
the best system that is available if
you're gonna look just at the efficacy
of a health care system is probably
Switzerland system there you have what
is essentially a massive individual
mandate where you are forced to pay for
health insurance yourself from your own
pocket to a certain percentage of your
income and then the government may
supplement the rest if you can't
actually afford health care insurance
but it's still largely private I mean
meeting their private health care
services in Switzerland in France most
of the hospitals are still private most
of the care is still private it's just
there's heavy government subsidization
of private care when Camilla Harris
talks about a full takeover of the
government industry she's talking about
something that looks more like the UK or
Canada and that is a radical shift from
what we have in the United States by the
way the French health care system which
looks a lot more like the United States
as health care system actually then it
looks like Canada or the UK
even the French health care system right
now is experiencing massive shortages of
doctors in the very near future because
it turns out that when government pays
reimbursement rates those reimbursement
rates are not high enough to keep
doctors in the industry in other words
when it comes to health care policy if
you actually want the best what you need
is a free market if you want
universality you need some sort of
safety net in the United States we have
Medicaid we have Medicare these are
safety nets that exist on the
governmental level I would prefer that
most of these social safety net be
devolved to the local level and the
communities be responsible for picking
up the slack for people who are members
of those communities as opposed to these
massive federal programs but nobody in
the united states is really very much in
favor of the abolition of everyone's
health insurance programs when schultz
says we can't afford this when schultz
says it's gonna bankrupt the country
he's exactly right about that he's
exactly right and the fact is again the
United States has health problems in the
health problems in the United States
don't match up to Norway like the people
in the United States are not the same as
the people in Norway you can't compare
the two in terms of health problems in
terms of diversity in terms of the age
in terms of income it's just not
comparable but I love that Democrats
have this one-size-fits-all solution
that most Americans don't like so
Schultz is more moderate on this and
it's a reason why Democrats feel
threatened by him and then there's
Howard Schultz on the debt so here as
Schultz talking about a problem that no
one wants to talk about the fact that we
have 21 trillion dollars in debt in the
United States economy right now I think
the greatest threat domestically to the
country is this 21 trillion dollar debt
hanging over the cloud of America and
future generations and the fact that
interest rates are going up we're going
to be paying close to over 400 billion
dollars in interest expense which i
think is the the number one or number
two issue in terms of federal expense to
the country the only way we're going to
get out of that is we've got to grow the
economy in my view four percent or
greater and then we have to go after
entitlements okay all of that is a
hundred percent true and what he's
saying there is more conservative than
what Donald Trump has said on the issue
Trump himself said he didn't want to
touch entitlements you need to touch
entitlements you know honestly if Howard
Schultz runs as an independent on this
on this platform it's doubtful a lot of
Republicans are gonna break with Trump
just because Trump is in such a
polarizing figure either love him or you
hate him at this point
but are there middle-of-the-road
Democrats who will break for Howard
Schultz I think there are and I think
that's why these people are scared to
death of him I think they are scared to
death the Michael Bloomberg or Howard
Schultz runs and that Howard Schultz
wins 15-20 percent of the vote they are
scared to death they don't have anyone
electrifying who is currently running
they need somebody who's gonna win 50
percent of the vote and the possibility
of a serious third-party candidacy doing
damage is very real Americans don't like
either party right now look at the polls
when Howard Schultz blasts both parties
he is not wrong here are Schultz
blasting both parties the other day both
parties are consistently not doing
what's necessary on behalf of the
American people and aren't engaged every
single day in revenge politics well we
are sitting today with approximately 21
and a half trillion dollars of debt
which is a reckless example not only of
Republicans but of Denver
as well as a reckless failure of their
constitutional responsibility okay all
of this is true and again you know I if
I'm a Democrat I'm scared of Howard
Schultz which is why they're screaming
at him right now now meanwhile does that
mean that they're gonna change their
policies of course not it means they're
gonna keep doubling down on radicalism
and then hope that Howard Schultz
withdraws out of the goodness of his
heart and that the American people
reject him simply because they hate
Trump so much so Jamelle Bouie another
leftist on the New York Times editorial
board which is just what they need they
need another member of the leftist cadre
over the New York Times very important
they must never hire an actual concern
they're still by the way not a single
person of whom I am aware who who's on
the editorial board or who writes
columns for The Washington Post for The
New York Times for Time magazine for any
of these places who plans on voting for
Trump in 2020 not one which is amazing
because half the country's gonna vote
for Trump but Jamelle Bouie was recently
hired over at the New York Times and he
has an article today about how Ocasio
Cortez Warren in Sanders under the
future of the United States and how they
represents the history of the United
States now they may in fact be the
future of the United States if the
future of the United States is suicide
but the case that America's history is
deeply intertwined with radical
redistribution ISM is simply nonsense
nonetheless Democrats are gonna continue
to make this case they feel like Trump's
unpopularity is a window for them to
push as hard left as they want to push
so here's Jamelle Bouie he says an old
but still potent critique has reemerged
in American politics one that holds
concentrated wealth and perhaps American
capitalism itself as an immigrant to the
Democratic Society we want to build the
basic idea holds that holds capitalism
as as at best and an easy partner
with our democratic values at worst it
arose them completely undermining the
social and material basis of Republican
citizenship as envisioned by the
American revolutionaries since the start
of the new year this thinking has become
especially prominent and then he quotes
alexandre Ocasio Cortez and Elizabeth
Warren
this is idiocy of course the idea that
capitalism is inimical to American
democratic values it's just not true now
aristocratic concentration of wealth is
inimical to American values if you read
Alexis de Tocqueville III Thomas
Jefferson if you read of the founding
fathers one of the things that they were
hoping to escape in Europe was this idea
of an aristocrat
wealth system in which the centralized
government passed on favors to a select
few that they were seeking to avoid but
a free-market system where people can
freely alienate their labor and trade
goods and services for other goods and
services that was something all the
founders were in favor of now the United
States was also uniquely blessed de
Tocqueville talks about this the United
States was uniquely blessed with an
extraordinary level of middle class
development specifically because we
lived on a relatively uncultivated
continent with lots of free land for
everybody so it wasn't that hard to go
out there a stake your claim and
suddenly you were a middle-class farmer
but the idea that the solution was for
government to forcibly redistribute
wealth that was something that the
founders never contemplated and set up a
government to prevent yet Jamelle Bouie
makes the case that America has always
been in favor of such redistribution ISM
shall we say the evidence is rather
scanty of this so here is his his
suggestion he says some of these he says
most Americans tend not to think of
these egalitarian even anti-capitalist
sentiments as part of the nation's
intellectual heritage but Warren Ocasio
Cortes and similarly situated
politicians like Bernie Sanders are
drawing on influential currents in
American political history first of all
I should note that here he is ripping
off joseph alice's new book about the
founding fathers which has some serious
problems and recommended it on the show
but it's got some serious selective
reading problems here's Jamelle Bouie
again he says some of those stretch back
to the founding era despite his own
status as a wealthy slave holder Thomas
Jefferson was weary of extreme
disparities of wealth and thought it was
incompatible with Republican political
ideals commenting on the consequences of
this enormous inequality producing so
much misery to the bulk of mankind in
Europe he described his position in a
famous letter to James Madison in 1785
whenever there is in any country on
cultivated lands an unemployed poor it
is clear that the laws of property have
been so far extended as to violate
natural right the earth is given as a
common stock for man to labour and live
on if for the encouragement of industry
we allow it to be appropriated we must
take care that other employment must be
furnished to those excluded from the
appropriation okay what he's
specifically talking about there is the
idea that rich people are gonna have
control of all the land and poor people
won't be able to work on the land
well that's written into American law
there's something called adverse
possession in American law in which if I
buy a huge
active land and I don't do anything with
it for 20 years and you without my
knowledge go and cultivate a piece of
that land and turn it into your family
farm you actually now have possession of
it under American law well that he's
certainly not talking about the forcible
extraction of wealth from people at the
key part of that phrase when when
Jefferson is writing is whenever there
is in any country uncultivated lands and
unemployed poor hay when where the
uncultivated lands and then I love this
he's just fast forwards to Eugene Debs
no stop in the middle so Jamelle Bouie
goes from Thomas Jefferson who's a
radical a radical decentralized power
guy he didn't want power centralized in
a government at all Jefferson was closer
to anarcho-capitalism than he was to a
centralized government Marxism I love
this Jamelle Bouie skips from him from
from this representation of Jefferson
forward to Eugene Debs
an actual socialist in the early
twentieth century and then suggest that
socialism is written into the American
compact you may have missed some folks
like in between and around and like in
the Constitution and the Federalist
Papers and like all of American history
you may have missed there but I guess if
you quote Eugene debb's who is
legitimately a socialist then I suppose
that we're on solid ground now
Jamelle Bouie concludes by the end of
the 20th century's the insights of the
New Deal period have been smothered by
corporate power and its political allies
with predictable consequences we live
with a narrow politics where democratic
deliberation rarely touches the
fundamental questions of power and
ownership that's weird cuz it seems to
me that every five seconds we're
discussing how much wealth to
expropriate from people who have already
paid their taxes he says as Americans
across the political spectrum gear up to
try to deny President Trump a second
term in office all of this may seem
divisive a distraction from the
emergency at hand just the opposite is
true
Trump's presidency is a symptom of
profound Democratic weakness should he
lose in 2020 that will be the beginning
of a recovery we'll still need to
rethink and rebuild our democracy and
that has to include a reimagining of the
economy on which it rests well okay so
the Democrats have made a mistake here
they are misinterpreting dislike for
President Trump who is in truth a
relatively unlikable fellow they are now
misinterpreting lack of support for
President Trump with support of
full-scale Eugene v-dub socialism and
then
they wonder why maybe Howard Schultz is
dangerous to their program and all they
have to do is not be crazy and they
can't even do that it's just amazing
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like today America is an amazing
place so there was a an Air Force
veteran with no family and he passed
away and there was a story about this
that folks and then he had nobody to
show up in his funeral well folks like
Jake Tapper some other folks in the
media they made the case that folks
should show up to this guy's funeral
again Air Force veteran had no family
and thousands of people showed up to the
funeral of a person they did not know
that's an amazing thing here's a picture
if you can't see it of a line of cars
it's like Field of Dreams a line of cars
stretching off into the horizon for
people showing up to pay homage to an
Air Force veteran with no family who was
buried after fears that no one would
actually attend his funeral it's an
amazing amazing thing it's an amazing
country it really is there's so many
good people in this country and the fact
that some people in politics want to
polarize us from one another so we can
attack each other's wealth or attack
each other by identity group it's really
it's really gross this is what America
is all about people showing up to the
funeral of a person but they didn't even
know you know the highest form of
charity it says in Jewish thought isn't
going to somebody's funeral because it's
charity that can never be reciprocated
obviously the fact that Americans still
understand that they owe something to
veterans who with whom they are not
related it's just it's an amazing thing
okay other things that I like today so
it's amazing how members of the LGBT
community are considered a one giant one
giant kind of intellectual bloc that
obviously is not true and it simply is
not true if you're a lesbian or a gay
person there is no reason that you
should buy into the propaganda that
suggests that men can become women and
women can become men and yet if you are
a lesbian or a gay person who believes
in biological sex you will be ostracized
just the same way any conservative would
be so for example there was a there was
a an event at Heritage Foundation and
carrots an skia feminist lawyer and
spokeswoman from women's liberation
front spoke against the so called
equality act denouncing the transgender
and gender identity movement is an anti
woman and anti lesbian in particular
which makes perfect sense I mean if you
are a lesbian presumably you prefer
members of your same sex well in order
for that's made
any sons sex has to be in a non
changeable category otherwise a man
could be a woman I mean we have seen
weird situations like this my sister
used to teach at a college and she told
me that there was a situation in which a
man who identified as queer right
meaning that he was not straight and a
woman who identified as transgender and
queer ended up marrying each other so it
was just a man and a woman marrying each
other but they had weird labels that
they had attached to this health but as
a normal marriage okay but apparently if
you are in the lesbian or gay community
you must be forced to abide by dictates
that actually make your own view of
sexual orientation and sex relatively
obsolete here are some members of a
panel at Heritage Foundation talking
about this using male pronouns to talk
about a convicted male rapist who
identifies as transgender and first
female pronouns it doesn't matter that
he sexually assaulted two women in a
women's prison after being transferred
there to call a male rapist he okay and
that's Julia Beck who is a lesbian
talking about this it is pretty amazing
it is pretty amazing but that is the
world in which we now live and it's
pretty ugly world okay time for some
things that I hate so now appears that
there is no plan in Afghanistan
President Trump is about to sign a new
peace deal apparently with the Taliban
in Afghanistan now there was a case we
made that originally when we invaded
Afghanistan the entire goal is just to
destroy the Taliban and then prop
somebody else up and leave we tried that
and apparently that has failed I've
talked to many people who have served in
the military in Afghanistan people who
have been in positions of power in
Afghanistan and what they say is that
unless you are willing to cross the
border and do the heavy lifting of going
after terrorists in Pakistan unless
you're willing to take off the Pakistani
government the Taliban was always going
to end up retaking Afghanistan now the
question is whether the United States
going to hastily withdraw from
Afghanistan and turn the country back
over to the Taliban just as in Syria
there seems to be a real desire for
America to withdraw the fact is that if
America does with Rob the Taliban will
take over again it will one again once
again become a safe harbor for
terrorists we'll ignore it for ten years
and then there will be a terrorist
attack the entire reason we went into
Afghanistan again was because of 9/11
this was the good war supposedly
according to Barack Obama even that good
war is now being undermined by the idea
that the United States has to pull out
as fast as possible damn the future
consequences well according to the New
York Times a hasty American withdrawal
would erode the authority and legitimacy
of the Afghan government raising the
risk that the Taliban can recapture
control of the country short of that it
couldn't consign Afghanistan to a
protracted bloody civil war here's the
thing about American foreign policy
there are not always great answers
sometimes the best answer is just a
muddle through and it seems like most
presidents kind of get this president
Trump gets this so did Barack Obama the
Barack Obama wanted to pull out of
Afghanistan too he didn't because once
you get in that chair and information
comes across your desk you now have to
make difficult decisions it's easy to
campaign on the isolationism that is
popular among Americans it is much
harder to govern from that popul popular
isolationism when you want to keep
America safe all of which suggests the
American people should get real about
their own foreign policy if you want to
be safe that means that we are going to
have to be in places that are
uncomfortable if however you are willing
to take the sacrifice of Americans at
home being in more danger then you can
be a little bit more isolationist than
then you might otherwise necessarily be
but let's be straight about the choices
that are being made
let's not fib and say we can have
everything a fully isolationist foreign
policy and a less dangerous world it
doesn't work that way already well we
will be back here a little bit later
with two more hours if my cold can bear
it we'll see you there later or we'll
see you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19